[Music]
Channing Tatum still has love and
respect for his ex-wife Jenna Dewan
Channing took to Instagram on Sunday to
wish Jenna a happy Mother's Day
the pair share four-year-old daughter
Everly despite announcing their split in
April Jenna told ET she was still
looking forward to Mother's Day I always
want Mother's Day to be like family I
want to do something together I want to
be with Emmy and just have a really nice
day and then the next day I want to go
spa you know that's what I want the
balance I want the mummy time and then I
want the me time yeah while the world of
dance hosts enjoys quality time with her
little girl there's one thing she
doesn't look forward to on the holiday
no one wants anything I'm cooking
breakfast for anybody ever maybe a few
more years she'd make me a card and her
biggest thing is Color Me Mine Oh she'll
go and make me a cup I have like you
know a million for birthdays and
everything it's like coffee mugs galore
at my own a little bit